[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much thank you good
evening and welcome to the conflict zone
debate coming to you from Berlin and
live on Facebook
not since the Cold War has German
foreign policy faced such serious tests
in such a volatile period North Korea
the new Trump administration icy
relations with Russia and Turkey the
failure to cope with refugees and
migrants who continue to flee their home
countries many hundreds of them dying in
the attempt to reach Europe what kinds
of solutions do Germany's politicians
have to offer to these crises what role
should the country play in the
international arena should the next
German government be doing more or less
or pursuing different goals well six
representatives of the main political
parties are with us tonight in the
studio and our audience will be asking
them some searching questions they are
Michael link from the liberal FDP party
he's a former junior minister in the
German Foreign Ministry and was eight
years in Parliament Christian Anderson
from the populist AFD alternative for
Germany party she's campaigning for the
Bundestag from the local council in
Limburg where she heads the AFD faction
Stephanie Beck is a member of the Left
Party in the Bundestag and sits on its
Foreign Affairs Committee andreas Nick
from the governing Christian Democrats
the CDU also a member of the Bundestag
Foreign Affairs Committee as is our
Midnapore foreign policy spokesman for
the Green Party and Ralph Stegner from
the social democrat SPD the junior
partner in the current coalition
he leads the party in schleswig-holstein
ladies and gentlemen that's our panel
so I'm going to take our first question
from the audience it's on North Korea
and it comes from Alexandre veldt's
rumba please go ahead
hello Germany has called for dialogue
and diplomacy over the crisis and North
Korea if you would stand in front of Kim
jung-un today what exactly would you say
to him thank you very much what I'd like
to do is kick off with a couple of quick
sentences from each of you what would
you say to King John um today and why
let's start with if you would like
Michael link can you start us and we'll
go down the line okay thanks for the
question well that's a question which
really unites us all because we are all
without a magic key for this problem
because he thinks he's extremely strong
and he hopes of course that he can
intimidate all of us but it's extremely
important to tell him very clearly you
have lost all friends I would tell him
you have lost all friends and we will
make sure by sanctions and by other
means that you will not get any more
resources for your weapons so think
twice before you act and before you
continue on your aggressive path
Christian Andersen yeah I agree I would
I would certainly tell him he needs to
cut it out and he needs to cut it out
immediately the problem we're talking
about here is nuclear weapons and it is
unacceptable that somebody somebody like
that has the power over what it's like
that
so in the name of peace of the world we
need to make sure that he will not act
on that I think when he is provocative
then we should stay calm and we should
offer him back to the six-party talks
with China Japan with South South Korea
with the United States of course and I
think he should end his nuclear
ambitions and on the other side South
Korea and the United States should
freeze their maneuvers is Nick I think
there's a short-term priority and the
longer-term priority
the short-term priority is to avoid
escalation of nuclear warfare or by
military confrontation by accident and I
think that should be made clear that
this is in the mutual interest of
everyone involved and the second
priority for the medium term should be
to find a framework under which we could
clarify what his real interests are is
this aggression or is it mainly using
nuclear weapons as a life insurance for
his regime and try to find a diplomatic
framework whether it's six-party talks
was as p5 plus 1 we have made clear we
were willing to participate in something
like that like we did in Iran and I
think that is one important step to
reduce the risk of escalation so what do
you say in actually your actual words
he's standing before you what do you say
to him don't be aggressive make sure
that you avoid military escalation by
accident and let's find a framework
under which we can peacefully discuss
how to resolve differences in the region
our rapport I would ask him what they
want I have no idea what question is
what do you want and of course the
question is what's the price for from
coming back to the table of the
negotiations and of course we has to
understand you question is you you have
to understand that a world community is
sticking together and we be made to have
an alliance with China with Japan and
South Korea and on that and he can see
that you can see that on the question of
of the coal shipments for example being
bent and this is bad for him so the
question is what's the price for for
negotiations and what surprise for for
getting rid of his nuclear arsenal so
you want to do a deal you sit down the
deal is gonna have a price I would I
would first you want to find out exactly
what the prices you know did the problem
in North Korea is we do not have any
influence and we do not have any
insights so we have to talk rough
Stegner what part of the question is
already the answer talking rather than
radical tweets or something like that
and asking him what he wants is right as
well and I will tell him that the world
is united in not tolerating and nuclear
arms race and there's nothing to win for
him but maybe more to lose he has
to support his population and has to
have a well being for his people there
whether we have infants or not is a very
difficult question I don't know where
the talks will answer that question but
talking is better than anything else
Jake if I could come back to you why do
you think he should listen to somebody
from Germany
what's Germany got to offer well indeed
we have limited influence on North Korea
as has almost anybody else with the
exception of China there is a question
whether he might be interested over time
in relations that may help to improve
the livelihood of his people which is in
a desperate situation we are very saying
you might dangle the idea of economic
support in front of it whether I would
call it support or at least improvement
of the livelihood of its people we are
important trading partner to many of his
neighbors in the region we have a vested
interest in stability and that should
make us a credible party to talk to he's
learned a lesson hasn't he which a lot
of people learn in politics which if you
have a big gun and you start firing it
people are going to listen to you hunter
I think we as Germans has have one thing
to offer this is the experience of the
reunification we can discuss discuss
with him that we managed it and I think
there are people even in North Korea who
are interested in our experiences and
suggesting he wants to unify with the
South there are people on both sides who
are discussing reunification we have a
new president in South Korea and now and
he is interested in a different way than
their president before but one kills his
opponents and the other one fights
elections with them some difference
there's Kim Jung hoon would say and I
think we have to try to learn how see
how he sees the world he would say yeah
but there are maneuvers between the
United States and South Korea so what I
would suggest is we should make freezing
in this Minerva's he has to say he will
stop his nuclear ambitions and then we
can go back to talk and I think this is
the best and this is possible way
Christine Anderson can you use you said
tell him to cut it out yes I can yeah
assuming assuming that he doesn't
you afford to leave him to play with his
toys and simply walk away no of course
not so America has a right to prevent
him I'm sorry
America has a right to prevent him from
using those toys it has America a right
to do that they don't have a right to do
that unless they have a goal from the UN
I would say they can I'm sorry Russia
and China are blocking that in the
Security Council does America have a
right then we need to get them all on a
table and we need to talk about that
that's all going so well these days is
it well we should we should delays to
try it but I just had another idea maybe
maybe the word reunification I just
heard here maybe he is trying to prevent
just that maybe the peace with the world
has just come to become too peaceful for
him I don't know how he tics but we need
to we need to stop him and we can't just
let him go undoing Michael slightly
larger question here do you think
Germany should play a bigger role in a
dangerous world bigger role than it has
done up till now I think so I think so
because we have a role to play in
defending the multilateral liberal
international order and that means for
North Korea yes certainly we should play
a role but not as Germany alone but as
part of the EU look at what the EU could
could do and Germany together with the
u.s. strong EU member in the Iran talks
Iran shows you that takes time we don't
have the time so much in North Korea I
agree with you but let's begin where he
wants something he meets spare parts
finance resources for what he is doing
we can do more the latest sanctions are
a good step forward we can do more from
depriving him getting the resources he
needs to continue his path the Americans
who went to see Kim jong-un in 2014 came
away saying the North Koreans are not
going to give up their nuclear weapons
it's a non-starter
we tried pressuring threatening
negotiating trying to leverage China
everybody's tried all that and it's not
working so what are you left with
well of course I'm not the defender or
here to to explain what president from
things there I a question myself ask
myself would he
once there but just being loud and just
imitating the noise the noisy approach
of course of some news from North Korea
is not helpful but again let's begin
where North Korea needs something let's
begin where they are in need of
resources and technology for the weapons
here we can indeed do more rumors are
about countries like sometimes Egypt
Pakistan still selling something to him
well let's try to stop that line rough
Stegner if you accept the idea that
Germany should play a bigger role in a
dangerous world if you don't deal
forcefully with North Korea now what's
to stop another state playing the same
games further down the line well if you
would only talk to the nations that
share our values who are alone with
Iceland in Norway so that doesn't help
really I think one of the problems is
not only not many have nuclear weapons
yeah that's true but it's the problem is
not only North Korea but also that we
don't have enough unity among the the
other nations so first of all we should
come together with the Americans and the
Chinese and see that we get more unity
and then tell the North Koreans we won't
threaten you if you don't threaten us
and the Security Council is deadlocked
as you know yeah most important issues
so that unity isn't very there's a truth
but telling that this is difficult
doesn't mean that we can afford to give
it up see what's realistic rather than
what's difficult or easy what did you
think it was realistic to get out of the
confrontation between the big
superpowers and it happened because it
was tried long enough we had a cold war
that was ended and we are not threatened
by a nuclear war between the United
States and Russia anymore as Soviet
Union so things can change but it takes
a while and there's no reasonable that
turned Hilton negotiating to talk and
Germany can play a big role because we
are economic power and and we very much
benefited from what happened after World
War two so I think we can play a role in
negotiating and lowering tensions and
peace talks and and those kind of things
rather
and having to escalate everything and
make an arms races and that kind of
stuff
Oh make no report the greens would want
to play that role with absolutely but
not as Germany but as a European Union
we are too small as Germany you know
you're definitely affected by a by a
military escalation in East Asia first
because you're entangled economically
with the region and second because
Berlin geographically is closer to
Pyongyang and then Washington DC is so
we have to engage but we can't do it as
Germany we have to do it as a European
Union and we have to to stay together on
that but as as Stephanie [ __ ]
mentioned we have a president now in
South Korea who for example proposed the
idea of one country two systems we never
got an answer from North Korea we have
to come to an models of to a models of
of of talking so we can at least get
some some reactions to that what is what
is happening at to the proposals which
are now there and there are a lot of
them I wonder if any of the audience has
heard anything they'd subscribe to or to
which they would violently object is
there anybody who wants to make a
comment all right okay let's go to our
second question again from the audience
Dina schmekel could we have your
question please thank you in the last
eight months we've seen some quite
erratic behavior from the new US
president in your opinion are the United
States under President Trump still a
reliable ally thank you very much Bob
Stegner is a reliable ally yes they are
because America is a strong democracy
and they survived at President Trump I
think although in comparison I mean Bush
was a liberal intellectual in comparison
with Trump so it has gotten really worse
but I guess the American Americans have
a strong democracy and we also have to
talk to Trump and maybe he has to
experience that some of his crazy ideas
won't get support anywhere in the world
so you want to be able to learn your
party leader Martin Schultz has been
pretty blunt and quite tensioned about
on these views about Trump hasn't he I
mean he said accused him of sowing chaos
at home and abroad and well freedom of
speech so
I would say that distance how much
distance do you want to put between you
and the trumpet Minister well it doesn't
have really to be polite to somebody who
was insulting the whole world and
endangering the world with his tweets
and all that and going against every
minority you would think of so I think
being blunt is a good thing to do and I
make you feel better does it or is it in
Germany's interest to be blunt I think
it's it's also it's smart to do so
because if you don't do that if you have
the impression that he can get away with
that that doesn't bet any anybody that
doesn't benefit anybody so being blunt
doesn't mean talking with them and maybe
he's able to learn I I'm an optimistic
person so I would suggest maybe even
from it's able to learn and you think
the CDU meanwhile has been pandering to
Donald Trump by promising that they'll
meet the 2 percent of GDP spending on
defense that only NATO leaders promised
at 2014 it is one of the big questions
in our election that the Conservatives
want to spend 30 billion euro a year
more for military and we rather want to
spend that for education families in the
future yeah but you signed up to this in
2040 as well no no there was they talked
about that there was never a decision of
the government
neither of the party Junior which
emergency memory coalition signed up to
it no no the co said you know you're
unreliable on this well you may say that
but there was no decision of the
government neither a decision of the
Parliament so therefore I think that's a
question of debate in our election
campaign and yes mrs. Merkel I think
doesn't stand up enough against Donald
Trump that would be useful and good and
therefore we have a difference between
Social Democrats and conservatives here
ok I'm Jess Nick do you want to come
back on that I think the two-percent
framework was agreed a long a time
before Donald Trump took the presidency
it was a creeper social democratic
Chancellor's and foreign ministers so
it's interesting to see that that
doesn't count anymore to the Social
Democrats when it is helped apparently
helpful in an election I think 2% is a
very academic debate I think what we
should agree on is that in a world that
has
increasing security challenges where we
are required to take more responsibility
for our security where we have to take
more responsibility for stability in our
immediate neighborhood in the Middle
East in northern Africa that we should
provide our military with the means
necessary so that they can do these
missions with the best equipment
possible whether that ultimately ends up
there 2% is a statistical issue I would
like to broaden that perspective if
we're talking about a three percent
objective including what we need to
spend on development aid on diplomacy on
other aspects of our integrated foreign
policy but in this regard more
responsibilities in the security
environment is an important factor you
want a bigger army and that you think
that helps you talk with a louder voice
we need at least to catch up on what we
have excessively done in savings in the
military for the last 20 years we also
need to improve European cooperation as
the Chancellor said in the in the
tutoring speech we need to take more
responsibility for our own destiny but
don't you need to do that in conjunction
also with our European partners I'm
curious about why you want to spend more
on defense because every time there's a
crisis the German view is there's no
military solution in Ukraine and Crimea
there was no military solution to
despite the fact that President Putin
had had taken one himself in North Korea
there's no military solution we're told
if there's no military solution to all
these crises what do you want a bigger
army for what important aspect of
deterrence is that an army is necessary
for not to have to be used in the future
where you're not going to use it we have
more security challenges we have to
support our allies in Lithuania in
Poland in other countries against the
threat from from Russia we have
engagements missions of our military
under e EU and UN mandates in a number
of countries in Africa and I want to
make sure that soldiers that we have to
send into inter missions with our
personal vote in the Bundestag equipped
in the best possible way to keep them
out of harm
rhasta go
we didn't hear you can use having a good
army that's okay but not rising up the
cost for 30 million a year that's a big
difference I think you want to send our
soldiers into missions for which your
party votes in Parliament every time
without providing them with adequate
material and that's irresponsible I'm
ignoring poor what I didn't get yet is
what the money is for I was in a member
of of inquiry comedies for for four
years asking the question how it comes
that a lot of money has been burned
within infra in fact 'iv structures of
the Bundeswehr burning more money
doesn't mean more security first second
they don't say what the money is for you
spent 2% of the GDP for generous
pensions you can't fulfill them with the
goals and then the commitment you gave
internationally this is no more security
and the last one is we need a reform
within the within the German army and
within the European Union we need more
cooperation you spend more money you
kill the pressure for the reform so this
is what we are opposing it so you watch
the treatment you want to see greater
German defense engagement in NATO and
the EU is that right you you ask the
question of military solutions there
never are military solutions but
military sometimes can create winds of
opportunity for other solutions eases
Isis Isis is over running Mosul and it
is going after but that we have to stop
them militarily so there are moments
when you need military action but then
you need solutions in other levels you
need to pull it at policy state building
and so on and so on
we should spend the money for that you
don't have enough capacity for it Stefan
levy
your party voted at your conference in
June to remove US and NATO
infrastructure in Germany of the kind
that could be used against Russia so you
don't support this idea of a new
muscular Germany in the in the dangerous
world yes you are right I think you were
in Germany I think we have a bigger role
we have a great responsibility in the
world
I don't think that we should use our
military forces for that there are good
things to use our bigger role I will
bring the example you just mentioned the
Minsk talks about the future of Ukraine
I think it was the best way to discuss
the situation between Ukraine and Russia
and I think the German government did a
wonderful job there but really you have
a frozen conflict and people have done
we have is good we have a frozen
conflict and I'm very happy that we
don't have a hot conflict and so I think
that was the right decision on the other
hand to being number three and weapon
exports worldwide this is not the
responsibility we have I think this will
make our world more unsafe this will
cause a lot of refugees and so I think
yes Germany had a bigger role but the
question is what do we do with it
Christine Anderson you were nodding your
head in agreement we don't see but first
of all I am really glad mr. stigma I'm
really really glad to finally hear from
you that you at least acknowledge that
Donald Trump is the president of the
United States to my knowledge you failed
to congratulate him and as I do remember
that our bundes president right now even
called him a hate preacher very
interesting however I find you judged
for insulting the whole world why you
cannot keep back your insults I find
that very interesting
if they think the knows very well what I
just meant so Christine is no any help
to the question is he a reliable partner
or not this Trumper reliable partner
well there's a lot of things that he
said that are true well first of all and
we can't pump up the army all the time
we can't do that then it was mentioned
Isis yeah we do need to defeat Isis but
then the question has to be asked why
are they still there why do they still
exist when I think back on the Iraq
Creek war the u.s. went in and they took
apart this whole country in like two two
weeks or something like that and now
they are really trying to tell me they
cannot get rid of a bunch of morons down
there what is what is going wrong there
okay so you are still a supporter of
Trump you remain a supporter of Trump
usually spoken the truth a lot of people
say the United States the American
people voted for him and I of course
respect and acknowledge him since
they're our friends and allies like I
always hear or are they not
well this nominee for the partnership
with the United States is not based on
the President and who was elected the
the partnership is based on and on Pete
and the people and the values and the
democracy
[Applause]
the use of our democracy in our society
are also democracy and we have to
acknowledge that a leader I I was I was
banned from I was affected by their but
a Muslim ban in the beginning of the
year which was a bizarre thing because
I'm the vice president of the US German
friendship group okay they didn't let me
in I was asked all the time if I'm now
Farah what with being a translate trans
Atlantis's the answer is America my
America are those people who quitted
their their offices and went today to
the airport fighting for people like me
this is America two and then three
America definitely isn't viable but the
president is not five hundred thousand
people going around once a month and and
demonstrating against the most sexist
election campaign in the history of
mankind and these are our people a very
quick comment your party leader
Christian Linda says that sustaining the
transatlantic relationship should be the
next government's top foreign policy
priority is that right well certainly
and absolutely so's transatlantic
relations have been built for stormy
weather not for good weather and we are
in stormy weather because of an
outrageous US president who is not even
online on one line with his own
political party I'm surprised to hear a
defense of racist positions from you
well maybe because of your position
political party of course also it has
open questions to answer in terms of
racism when I hear some of what your
candidates and colleagues are saying
very clearly very clearly therefore may
is the transatlantic relations still top
of the agenda indeed we would try to
keep the United States of America as
engaged as possible in transatlantic
relations we have instruments for that
thanks God we have the US Congress which
is well prepared to tame even a u.s.
president who is not respecting the
institution's so I trust on the majority
and on the opposition in the US Congress
for strong transatlantic relations all
right I wonder in the audience how many
people still think that Donald Trump is
a reliable partner for Germany can we
see a show
who thinks he's a reliable partner not
many I see one hand two hands that's it
the rest of you convinced he's no longer
a reliable partners all right do I get
that right all right okay thank you
let's move on our next question is on
Russia and it's from Julia Schuster
Julia Shuster hello I would like to know
in your opinion what should be done
about the tension between Russia and
Germany also what are the chances of a
more open and cooperative relationship
in a new future thank you very much
Omid no report you must start us off on
that the Greens have been strong
supporters of sanctions against Russia
endless sanctions sanctions without a
deadline goes on and on no no you know
first there won't be a peace order in
Europe without Russia second we
definitely need strong ties of Tyler
with Russia third I would love to see
the sanctions being revoked immediately
but it depends a frosh is behavior they
were they came in today to the Crimea
and they occupied a part of of Ukraine
and we can't just just accept such kind
of breach of of international law and we
can't just ignore the huge concerns of
our partners in the east in the Eastern
European countries like Poland or the
Baltic States you say you you say you
can't accept it you have accepted it
everybody's accepted it haven't they we
didn't accept no we did not accept it
acceptable is the most overused words
absolutely this is why this is why we
implemented the sanctions and they can
go after Russia has has changed behavior
until Russia moves so the the relations
are frozen it is an actual reaction that
their action in Crimea led to the - the
sanctions they take the next action and
and and get get out of the country they
become with them immediately they want
to want to get get out of directions
there's no no no personally Michel link
your party leader seems to want to have
it both ways he said we have to get out
of the dead-end situation to break a
taboo I fear we must see the Crimea as a
permanent provisional arrangement how
can you have a permanent provisional
arrangements either permanent or it's
provisional which is it or you just want
to have it both ways well in the one
weeds stating with the obvious that we
cannot solve it fast
on the other side of course Christine
Linda was absolutely clear that there is
no chance for any sort of recognition of
the illegal annexation of Crimea by
Russia he was clear on that and he
repeated it several times and they think
it's indeed important to repeat it of
course you cannot make it part always
part of all talks as we did in the Iran
talks where we had together with Russia
a deal to do and not permanently
speaking on Crimea but at the same time
never forgetting about Crimea
so Crimea remains on the agenda also for
us from FDP but there are answers go on
there are preferences that we can solve
today and there are problems that we can
solve tomorrow and sanctions yes surely
should go on casselli no rightly said
there is a step-by-step approach if
Russia implements the Minsk agreement
then we can step-by-step reduce it and I
would rather try to create a tool to to
hear very clear today from SPD from
Welsh digna why the Foreign Minister now
suddenly offers a lifting of the
sanctions already for a ceasefire a
ceasefire is the absolute minimum
condition
there should be no lifting of the
sanctions if there is not a substantial
move by Russia you want to take that a
glad to answer that because in the
tradition of the policies of very brand
I would say we at that time didn't
accept that there were two German states
but we work gradually to overcome the
situation and I guess the sanctions
won't lead us anywhere
we don't accept the action against the
Crimean that was a violation of
international law we don't accept that
yet the sanctions won't lead us anywhere
I think it would be much more reasonable
to seek economic benefits in the way
that the Russians see that it doesn't
get there them anywhere I don't know
anybody who thinks that the sanctions
will lead to an improvement of a couple
falls behind the decisions of the
European Council I think that's not good
well we have to act together as
Europeans that's true and I don't
propose and that neither did that Sigma
Gabrielle proposed a German action by
our
nation alone we have to act as Europeans
but as your own party chairman said
things don't get us anywhere in the
moment so we have to overcome the
situation and the Minsk agreement is
there but we don't see any improvement
actually neither on both sides not only
on the Russian side and both things have
to be avoided we should not see the
Russians as the evil power of our and we
should not do the opposite as some
parties do applauding to everything mr.
Putin does but you're doing you're doing
both in a way you have a former
Chancellor god shadow who's just
accepted to go on the board of Rosneft
and and accept Russian money for a
second his second major job in in
Russian industry in Russian energy
business it's the same Garuda who was
against invading Iraq proposed by the
American president and followed by
Chancellor Merkel or by that at that
time leader of the Opposition America
and I think although I'm I'm not in
favor of his new job personally he
belongs to the person who worked for
better relations between Russia and
Germany and you're not again you're not
against his new job you're not in fact
not in the favor you embarrassed by it
I wouldn't decide it if I was the person
to say I wouldn't do that but it's his
own decision and and he is not a
politician anymore and jazz Nick you've
raised your eyebrows the I think Germany
interest would be much better saved if
Social Democrats all and about were more
carefully to avoid the impression that
they're overly interested in securing
personal slots or mr. Putin's payroll
now or in the future but politicians
from the Conservatives what they are
doing now how they earn their money I
mean we shouldn't do that here well I
know you don't like the subject that
that's clear but I think we have clearly
strategic interests as Germany in good
and constructive and peaceful
relationships with Russia but there's a
clear reference point for that and that
is a quarter of Paris that everyone in
Europe signed up to in 1990 as a
fundamental principle for how we work
and live together as states in Europe
renouncing violence
political instrument respecting the
territorial integrity of states smaller
and bigger and I think as soon as Russia
is making clear that they're willing to
return credibly to the principles of the
of the quarter of Paris sanctions are no
longer required but I let me remind you
that Rosneft is a saint's blacklisted
company under you you sanctions and I
think it is a disgrace for German
Chancellor to accept former German
Chancellor to accept a position on that
board there are some ambiguities in the
CDU's policy towards Russia though under
your pro sanctions but not at the
expense of your own nordstrom to deal
North stream to deal which brings
Russian gas to Germany some somehow that
is exempt from sanctions why why would
that and personally I'm hopefully pretty
skeptical about the North stream deal I
think it is not in the best interest of
our country but I have to accept that
this is a private investment decision
that it's a political decision there are
no such a such being just private
project nowhere on I don't know and you
don't find no one of them on the whole
earth can you tell explain to me what
instrument would be available to prevent
this if this is something that is
privately financed and decided there is
a law in Germany called out super Chavez
and you can you can you can just read it
and there are a lot of ways to avoid
such a project which is at the end of
the day of course push you know you're
having a chance to talking about the
keeping the you together as the highest
priority of German policy
we're totally accept and totally
endorsed as a sentence means that we
take for serious the concerns of the
countries in the Baltics for example and
the north wing to is exactly the
opposite of here I would say if we went
against every violation of European law
we should change things with Hungary for
instance you are conservative party
family with some the things Poland's to
polish do it we would be much more
credible against the Turkish premier if
we do it the same thing within the EU
and we are which boy do you apply and
what I want to come on to Turkey what I
want to say is
I want to say it's violating
international law which everybody can
see doesn't lead to sanctions in every
case so we have very different standards
talking about which nation we're talking
to and that's the possibility of
injustice the point all right Christine
Christine Anderson your party talks of
ending the sanctions policy deepening
economic cooperation with Russia in
other words giving them exactly what
they want
the textbook definition you're not
giving them what they want that is
however what we say and it's it's the
only right thing to do first of all we
keep talking about illegal elections as
if the Crimea was was taken by the
Russians and it is it is true so yeah
well you may laugh at me but just listen
for a moment you and there are there are
Carter how states deal with one another
but there's also another Carter you
Ankara where it says that every people
have the right to decide for themselves
where they want to be lied to and that's
what the people in Crimea did and I
would at least take into consideration
maybe it wasn't so illegal after all
what would happen in their point of the
matter is I'm talking point of the
matter is the I if they does want to end
those sanctions because they're
ridiculous and they're they're not doing
any good the the the the Russian people
are suffering from it and the Germans
suffering it from it too we are losing
jobs all of that no end to this okay
Christine Anderson you you your party
held a Russian Congress in Magdeburg not
so long ago and you sold copies of
putin's speeches there so you're
basically doing is PR for him these days
is that right i do not they were selling
speeches of putin i I don't have no
knowledge of that but I take I take your
word for it that they did
so what so what if the speeches are not
allowed to be read or or what are you
can you sell anybody else's speeches
those are the only ones which is wait
maybe maybe we will who knows maybe I'll
do is PR for him let's talk while we
have some time on Syria because mr.
Putin is busy protecting the Syrian
president Berta North stream if you
allow very quickly very quickly yeah
this is really worth mentioning because
no stream shows in an exemplary way that
here both parts of the gulf of the
author of the actual coalition in berlin
made enormous mistakes this is a project
which was made behind the bank of the
Baltic states of Sweden Finland Poland
Slovakia all right Lee criticizing it we
would better sooner than later stop that
project it is not helpful it is a very
bad project all right I just want very
before we leave this topic of Russia I
want to look briefly at its relationship
with Syria mr. Putin is busy protecting
the Syrian President Bashar al-assad who
the UN says is responsible for the death
of hundreds of thousands of people
what's your key message to mr. Putin on
Syria
would you like to think that this is a
wrong way to go about this question I
think Assad should not be protected yet
on the other hand without Russia and
other countries we won't get a peaceful
solution for Syria which is really
overdue for a long time because the
Syrian people have to suffer many people
can't come as refugees still many live
there under really bad conditions so not
exact accepting the Russian position on
that but neither accepting the position
of others because there's a war going on
they're supported by different nations I
would ask him if he shouldn't learn from
the huge mistakes the Americans did in
Iraq which was just to forget that after
a conflict you need something like in
process of national reconciliation which
is definitely not possible with the
person who is the symbol for chemical
weapons barrel bombs and reads for the
majority of the people of Syria and it's
not about regime change it's about the
question of how reconciliation can be
done and Resnik very quickly message to
Putin on Syria Russia
welcome as a responsible player in the
international system protecting
dictators who have staged warfare
against their own people is not part of
that Stefan lavish the problem in Syria
is that four out of five members
permanent members members of the United
Nations Security Council are active
there with military and without a
solution of the United Nations Security
Council this is wrong from all sides
from Putin and from the other sides to
Christina Anderson well I would say it
was high time that Russia got involved
in Syria because since they have Isis
has been put back and they have been put
in their place so I would say I would
say thank you sorry clear message to
President Putin that it was Russia once
to be a respected player on the
international scene here is an area
where it could really contribute to it
but not in taking sides or for Assad but
in really bringing also this regime
which is and let's not forget it at the
cause also of the refugee crisis in that
region not the Islamic state has air
force who bombed Aleppo but it was
Assad's troops
therefore Russia has a play has a role
to play there we want to see a
constructive Russian role we are waiting
for that in vain until now okay all
right we're going to move on now to the
next question which is on the issue of
refugees and it comes from Katie Redmond
Katie Redmond
thank you it's clear that the current
strategies to limit loss of life respect
migrant rights and ensure security in
Europe are not working
what are your creative solutions to the
migrant crisis thank you it's become
clear that the current strategies are
not working to limit loss of life
respect migrants rights and ensure
security in Europe what are your
creative proposals for solving the
migrant crisis Christine Anderson the
policy is not working what are you gonna
do why did I know I was going to be the
first to answer well what are the
creative the
well they people always talk about we
need to we need to stop the causes for
that and like I just said poutine sort
of got into there and he tried to stop
one of the causes what else do we have
to do we just need to get all on a table
and we need to discuss things and we
cannot and what is happening in Syria by
the way this is this is it's basically
cost these people they don't want to
leave their country to be frank but they
they're made to leave and when you when
you look at the the UN camps that the
for the refugees who's made to leave you
think I wanted getting to that when you
look at the UN refugee camps that were
set up in the in the neighbor states and
if mrs. Merkel was so humanitarian like
she always says where was she when the
world community decided to cut down on
the funds that these countries received
for for feeding clothing those these
people they got a woman to the future
$31 and it will cut down out of nowhere
to $12 where was mrs. Merkel when that
happened what I didn't hear word from
Christine Anderson what does the AFD
want to do with the migrant issue your
manifesto says German borders must be
closed this is this is your answer slam
the door she's not out no that's the
solution no this is not our answer to
the migrant crisis this is our answer to
our catastrophic internal security we
can't have this here I am a woman it's
somebody else's problem it's somebody
else's problem
no somebody else's problem it's my
problem I cannot just go out on the
street anymore at any old no I cannot no
I can
how do you know how do you know are you
facing please please if you all speak at
once nobody can hear anything
andreas Nick everyone seems to be agreed
in the CDU that there must be no repeat
of 2015 sad right
we were faced by a humanitarian crisis
that we had to resolve I understand but
we repeat we've made significant
progress that's why I don't accept the
initial proposition that vrf you seek
refugee crisis as such it's not solved I
think we have provided quite a
significant solution to stop the dying
in the in the Mediterranean between
Turkey and Greece thousand people have
that pose not abduction
I mean if let me finish we have a very
different situation in the central
Mediterranean of people from Africa
coming to to Sicily and southern Italy
this is a very different situation but I
think a lot of a number of the the key
components of the eu-turkey agreement
could be transferred to the situation
over time I think every solution I think
has to have three components so it's
better securing external borders
improving the livelihood of people in
their countries of origin in the
countries of transit and to a certain
extent also open legal transfers for
resettlement and immigration that is one
thing that we need to do in partnership
also with countries in central and
western Africa where most of those going
to Sicily at the moment and what about
the situation in Libya medicine some
frontier says the detention of migrants
is rotten to the core it's a thriving
Enterprise of kidnapping torture and
extortion migrants are locked up women
and girls are being raped by the guards
men are being beaten up do you think
this is a solution I have I'm absolutely
convinced that the solution for this
problem is not in Libya Libya is not a
viable State to provide safety for these
people we need to find these solutions
we the countries acquiescing at this
with the countries of origin mats and
some 40s as European states and Libyan
authorities are jointly implementing a
blockade on the ability of people to
seek safety
you go along with this it's even worse
than that we are paying militias now to
stop trafficking people across the
military and see now they do it and they
traffic narcotics this is the right idea
attitude to protect us they don't think
so what we are seeing in these days is
that there are a lot of short-term
measures are which are taken now which
are destroying the day long long term
solutions we need giving arms to the
army of child means that they gonna keep
away the refugees now but they're gonna
produce more refugees it's gonna happen
definitely and you can see there are a
lot of dirty deals with dictators in
these days you can see it in Egypt and
especially in Turkey which is a very
very bad idea and we should stop being
blackmailed by the hysteria of a fear of
those people who just are driving the
agenda of a couple of parties you
[Applause]
there's a lot of talk about addressing
the migrant problem at source in those
source countries people are beset by
corruption war unstable government
massive human rights abuse catastrophic
economic hardship how on earth are you
going to address those problems at
source it is a very very long term
process but if we don't start it then
the year 2015 was just the beginning
we have a situation that some people
speak about protecting our borders there
there was a time when protecting meant
protecting against enemies and now we
are protecting us against people who are
asking for our help this is a terrible
situation the only way to answer this is
have legal ways for migrants to give
them the opportunity to come with a ship
or with the airplane and not with these
silly boats this is an answer and I know
this will change something in our
country but I don't think that this is a
problem so no limits
we have no limits we would help people
who are asking for help if this is our
policy this is what we are fighting for
all right million decided to come which
the thing is we have now 67 million on
the world who are fleeing 67 million
this is the highest number what do you
think how many of them are coming to the
western states only five thousand by
both of them are asking for help in poor
countries and they are getting healthier
this is the truth let me say two things
one is we need common European action on
that thing and all every European
country doesn't only have to have the
advantages of the European Union but
also the burdens that go with that
second we have to go about the long term
things we talked about and third
everything what was said by the lady in
yellow here is outside of our we are
going to move on to the next question
which is on Turkey follows well from
that and it's from Sasha Sawa type Sasha
saw it I could we have your question
please thank you good evening how do you
Syst how do you insist on human rights
in Turkey but avoid alienating a huge
and important country thank you thank
you very much how do you insist on human
rights in Turkey but avoid alienating a
huge and important country does any of
you actually have a clear policy on that
you've got your hand up first first we
should we should how it should finally
take a clear language
we didn't for the last two years we had
a chancellor going to Turkey and meeting
up with with with air one one big before
the elections but refusing a meeting
with me they are positioned it is what I
would call campaigning for Arawa and
this was the worst thing you can do
second we of course have to to rethink
the customs union and the question of
economic aid which is not coming to the
people and they are not benefiting of it
but our wonders
and the last one is watching what's
going on in the southeast of the country
which is a civil war we have to stop for
selling arms to other one this is this
should be over now immediately because
he is using it again
own people and against it Kurdish
militias in in north of Syria we who are
fighting Isis by the way they are doing
it not about the Russians but this is
not our issue and Resnick III know the
government has cut back by more than
half on the number of weapons that are
being sold to Turkey and they're now
being considered on a case-by-case basis
but this is a country that is being
accused of massive human rights
violation how can how can you continue
to sell arms to them at all well as
we've seen these this week Turkey is now
starting to buy baptists massively in
Russia so that isn't it I think we have
the question I think race exactly I
think the dilemma that we face we're
dealing with Turkey it's a country in a
very important Jew strategic location
it's a society which which we are
interconnected with over 3 million
people of courage origin in our country
so every conflict every polarization of
the internal situation in Turkey has an
immediate impact also on our situation
in Germany and that's why we have to
keep running a very delicate balance
between very explicit very outspoken on
human rights on rule of law on freedom
of expression but at the same time
keeping keeping an open dialogue and
open especially to those parts of
Turkish society and this is at least 50%
who look towards Europe and towards West
the West for democratic and stable this
may not be a short-term solution but
that is something that is in the our
best interest medium and long term and
just Nick the the UN talks of massive
human rights violations hundreds of
alleged unlawful killings you still
provide the instruments to kill is there
no limit to the human rights violations
that Berlin will put up with is there no
limit to that I think we have to look
very carefully in case-by-case to what
is what is under consideration for under
weapons export but it would be I think
undirected I seem to really look at this
but at the issue of weapons as a key
question
of how we do was turkey away from very
other different other things to do with
that whether it's a German prisoners in
Turkish or prisons whether it's a
question whether we need to issue a
trevor warning at some point it's also a
question of how Germany wants to be seen
abroad as tolerating human rights abuses
even if they're from an ally on a
massive scale the problem is you start
to criticize Turkey when the first
German citizens are imprisoning and when
after 55 persons the journalists are in
prisons they started to undermine the
law and the rule of law in Turkey and
nobody said anything on that in the
German government after the first German
what was the rest everyone was screaming
this is the problem this is there never
has been red lines for that what's going
on this is simply not true I was in
Ankara the night before the the
chairwoman of HTP was put in prison and
I was supposed to meet her at 9:00 a.m.
and I learned that 3 a.m. in the night
and she was put in prison just before
we're going to meet her don't tell me we
were keeping quiet
Michael link the question was about not
alienating Turkey at the same time when
we criticized it yes indeed that's a
very important point our criticism is
not to Turkey not as Turkish people not
to Islam not to Turkish history our
criticism is to error on he's the one
who is responsible that these
negotiations with the EU need to be
stopped
ended because with a increasingly
authoritarian nearly dictatorial rule by
himself of course
this country has no chance since no
chance at all of joining the EU
therefore it's very important to speak
Frank and to support the opposition the
those at least who are still not jailed
in my professional life I had to observe
the light last four elections there as
the chief observer of the OSCE and I can
tell you very clearly the deterioration
of the situation is traumatic and
therefore we need to clearly address our
criticism and that is not of the Turkish
people but to air Dohan and his ruling
party
[Applause]
and I try and by the way and indeed it's
high time I agree with Hamid it's high
time that the good the government the
federal government finally takes
measures for example in stopping the
pre-accession financing of Turkey by the
EU that is over to Stephanie be the
first and most important step is that we
have to end the border deal between
Germany and Turkey and I think and
what's the plan be
once you've ended that deal people who
are asking for help will get help in the
EU and that not miss the ad one is
stopping them this is the plan as long
as he has this deal he can blackmail our
our government and he does it every day
our government is afraid to do something
against him because they are afraid of
the refugees which are coming if you end
this period I think this is a wrong
decision the second one is we have until
now a factory plant they are by climate
I this is terrible now that a German is
how is it now a German a company is
building tanks there this is terrible we
have to stop this right now but I have
one difference to you mr. link I don't
think that we ultimately should stop the
negotiations I I think we should suspend
it because the turkey of mr. everyone
cannot be part of the EU but if I am
thinking about the other half of the
Turkish people who are not in favor of
mr. Urwin I think we should have the
doors open for a maybe better future we
have a credible position on that because
we for a long time Social Democrats were
in favor of keeping the turkey within
Europe again other than the
Conservatives did and everyone started
out very progressive but now it's the
point where you can see another Turkish
people but the other one government
arrests people for just doing their work
fights against minorities so stopping
arms deals suspending the talks about
the European entrance in the European
Union and also stopping the money going
there and with clear German words
therefore I think Schulz is right and
and he has tough to add on very often
telling him that's not a thing to get
away with it I'm not have not the same
opinion as far as the refugee question
is concerned because what does it mean
cutting off the refugee deal that's not
the point I mean what Turkey is really
afraid of is the stopping of economic
ties they are they have many refugees in
their countries and they were and they
do something for them when we pay for
that too we support that and think I
think that's a good thing to do because
most of the refugees have a better life
in Turkey than they have in their
countries where they come from but we
should not be blackmailed accepting
human rights violations by the Turkish
government arresting people and spending
democracy more and more so clear words
no arms no money and also economic
pressure that I think has to be done by
the German government no report very
briefly please two points the first one
is you asked for a plan B yeah we have
to understand the necessity of the
refugee deal with Turkey started when
Germany pushed Greece so hard that they
they sacked more than half of the people
who are working with a more protection
this is why this has been necessary the
second one is the question of the
membership I would agree that we
shouldn't stop it we should we should
freeze it in this moment the reason for
that is as link Justice mentioned half
of the people in Turkey
refused their the way other one is going
before the only perspective these people
have is the European Union we shouldn't
shut down this perspective everyone is
trying to do Christina Anderson how do
you balance the importance of turkey
rights violation it's really surprised
that we're these three people agreeing
to what we've been having in our
manifesto for a long time of course we
have to stop the deal with with Turkey
and the point of the matter is Merkel
was making this deal with air Dewan
while the human right violations had
been going on for quite some time
she knew it so what what did you go down
there making the
deal for we are having someone who is
known to violate human rights he is
selecting who is going to Europe and who
is not we cannot accept that I'm very
sorry and you stunned the EU
negotiations you stopped the absolutely
absolutely
so slam the door effectively on time
we've been saying that all along alright
okay yeah thank you we're gonna move on
to our next question which is on brexit
and the EU and it's a question from a
smile to be rough please smile the
bureau some senior officials as we all
know sounded the idea of punishing the
UK over brexit what is in your opinion
more important being tough on Britain or
maintaining good relations all right
what's more important being tough on
Britain or maintaining good relations
Stefan leaving your party seems to lay
considerable blame on the EU for brexit
your manifesto says it's the antisocial
and undemocratic EU and the policies of
its member states which are boosting
authoritarian forces what kind of
attitude do you think Germany should
adopt towards the United Kingdom in the
light of brexit I think the European
Union is a very important thing we
should go on with it but we have to
change it this is what we in our
platform meant and regarding brexit I
want to say I think the people in the UK
will regret the decision what we have to
do as people in the European Union is to
show and this is not a punishment is to
show that such a decision has
consequences if you make a decision that
freedom of workforce in the European
Union is no longer allowed then you
cannot be part of the common market this
is not a punishment this is a logical
consequence and if you don't do that
then we will have some populist forces
and some other countries in France and
Netherlands if they see this is no
problem to go out of the European Union
then we should then we would support
them so because of that I would be very
clear as a European Union you made a
decision and this
we'll have consequences for you you made
a decision and it's a bad decision yes
and what if it what if it doesn't fail
you you're almost saying you need it to
fail to encourage everybody else to stay
in the European Union you want it to
fail don't you for Britain yeah what do
you mean you want brexit to fail you
want Britain to be worse off it what in
the future that I just describes the
legal situation if the people in the UK
are deciding that they don't want to
have a freedom of work force in the
European Union then it is their decision
it is the Democratic secession decision
but this has a clear consequence you
cannot be part of the common market this
is just what I say and this is a very
harsh consequence and I think the people
in UK will regret this decision aroused
a Glary your SPD economy minister
Brigitta supras is clear she expects
Britain to suffer more from brexit than
the German economy the same question to
you it's almost as if you want Britain
to suffer no it's a it's a tragedy for
Europe that this great country leaves
the European Union but it's a
catastrophe for England and there's a
lesson from that far up to England well
yes but there's a lesson from that young
people go out otherwise you get breaks
it's Trump's and all those things so
that's part of I don't think that a
majority of the British people really
wanted what's what's happening now the
point is I think we should not give up
the friendship with Great Britain we
shouldn't do anything to further that on
the other hand if you want to have the
privileges of the European Union but not
the burdens we will have we will see
many Great Britain's I could see the
list of nations that would follow on
that so therefore that doesn't work is
this but there is a solution to that are
you afraid of that a little bit there's
a solution to that I mean there could be
another election in Great Britain if
they see they don't get anywhere with
the negotiation that they changed their
course and I'm sorry leaving open the
possibility that they might want to come
back in yes and there would be an open
door for that would that well surely we
should have the door open because Europe
should always be a common union where
everybody can join who joins our values
like a link
full respect for the Democratic decision
of the UK people but of course it is and
are not qualifying it because we should
respect it at the other side of course
it's a pity it's a real pity for the EU
because it's weakening all of us in many
areas in many ways for example for me as
a free Democrat UK in trade issues and
many other issues of economic policy was
quite a good LR a very very often in the
discussions in the Council of Ministers
in the European Parliament etc but again
we have to respect it we should leave
the door open and we have to say a very
unpleasant truth through our UK friends
if you leave it then of course you have
to also to bear the consequences let's
take manufacturing many for example I'm
not sure whether many will be in future
also always produced in the UK so I
think yes there will be consequences
they will be damaging but not only for
the UK for all of us what do you think
the EU has learned from brexit what
lessons would you have liked the EU to
learn from brexit ask me and when the
breaks deal is done we still don't know
the terms Emmanuel macron says it's a
symptom of failure that we in Europe
must have the courage to face head-on do
you accept that well that is certainly
politically true and one of course one
lesson learned is because of brexit but
also because of the refugee crisis that
of course we need to maintain the EU
together while not centralizing it too
much we need to find the right way the
right way in to be strong where we need
to be strong defence trade currency etc
and to be decentralized where we need a
more loose approach like in taxation or
social security and just Nik just a few
hours before we just a few hours before
we came on air there was a speech by
jean-claude Juncker the president of the
European Commission who wants to push
ahead to a vision he said of some 30
countries using the euro a single EU
finance minister and he's dead set
against the kind of two-speed Europe
that both Germany and France have
proposed well how do you react to that
is that learning the lesson
a brexit well let me let me stress first
of all pretzel is a terribly bad idea
it's bad for the EU it's bad for the
United Kingdom it's not in Germany's
best interest we have a vested interest
in maintaining strong and friendly
relationships with United Kingdom but
that does and therefore I think the
terminology of punishment is it's not
the right way of thinking about it but
we have to protect the integrity of the
EU and the British government may have
to learn the hard way that you can't
have your cake and eat it which is their
current negotiating strategy apparently
and and they increasingly run the risk
of crashing out of the EU with the big
with a big crisis as you mentioned mr.
Juncker speech I think at least we are
having now an open debate on how we want
to take Europe further if praxis has one
positive but do you support its vision
if perhaps it has one positive that it
has made many of us more aware or where
the actual benefits are of the European
Union which are taken for granted way
too often we may have different ideas I
think we should have a clearer focus in
the European of solving the big issues
and that where you have overwhelming
public support for that that Europe
should deal with securing external
borders with providing security and
defense and also we stabilizing our
economies and making them more
competitive and I think in this regard
something like a European monetary fund
is probably a good idea whether you
should force the euro on everyone you
may have question marks but that is the
debate that is just starting but I think
we have a great opportunity which we
actually observe with the Oh have a
young provision on some of the UK
visions I have my reservations but I
think we have an excellent window of
opportunity with a president macro after
after the German election where for the
next two years to make it back a big
step ahead in Europe and make you more
coherent more successful and and more
positive in citizens views Christine
Anderson you're the big cheerleaders for
brexit aren't you your manifesto says
it's an example for Germany to follow
report that I would like to to cite
Angela Merkel she said the internal
cohesion of the European Union would
come before defending German exports to
the UK
she set that on October 6th in 216 and
that statement goes to show how little
Chancellor Merkel respects her own
people really clear that this young man
asked that question yes it is absolutely
right
UK it's about to be punished just to
teach them a lesson and just to let
every other country in Europe know down
even try it that's the message I'm
getting right okay thank you Andreas
Nick you want to come back on that again
protecting the integrity of the European
Union is something different than
punishing someone we have to pursue our
own strategic interests Germany is the
main beneficiary of European integration
we need to keep that going and we need
to make that a success because with our
geography with our history with our
economy that's what we depend on and
that's the policy that our government is
following all right we're going to come
to the final question which is from
because Schmidt
Nicholas Schmitt we can get a microphone
to you how quickly time is gone so if
you had to choose out of the United
Kingdom the United States Russia or
Turkey which one would you consider
Germany's closest partner under the
current circumstances and why if you had
to choose out of the UK the US Russia or
Turkey which would you consider
Germany's closest partner to be under
the current circumstances and why it
started this and rough Stegner I think
our closest partner stay the American
the United States of America
besides of the American government
current circumstances don't mean that
you have to agree with President Trump
we very much miss President Obama and we
will get a better president soon I would
I would think therefore they are still
our closest friend and Ally and that
should stay that way I made no report
it's United Kingdom as a member
of still member of a European Union and
then still member of this continent and
a democracy so so it's absolutely clear
to me that it's its UK first in our
relations between the four countries
whether it's in or out of the know
listen I'm very unhappy with tourism a
saying that the first step to get a
global Britain is installing a low tax
raises in the middle of a single market
and we can't let that happen
but at the end of the day this is the
this is Europe and and and UK is of
course part of it and and of course we
have we have strong ties and we have to
keep them fantastic I think as your
lists excluded France among the four
choices you've given it's definitely the
United States intention is it it's
definitely the United States with all
the reservations we have about about the
president the current administration but
over the long term this is the most
important relationship that we have and
we will make every effort to convince
the American people and the American
government to continue to play a
constructive role for the multilateral
international order because it's in
Germany's preeminent strategic interest
to sustain and develop that order it's
terrific
I wouldn't choose because States States
are not friends States are not friends
States are not partners sometimes we
have common interests sometimes we have
not we have to decided case-by-case and
so I wouldn't choose yeah but who would
you choose the question you wouldn't
choose any of them the question not
generally yes if you had to choose out
of the you just please mr. levy you
cannot ask me again and again I will not
make charts between countries we have
forgotten Israel we have forgotten
Poland we not kuba this may be your
friend
so so I think it is not wise to make a
chart list of states we have to talk
about the special topic and then we
should give an answer and not say this
is my closest friends that you are not
Christine Anderson well as the European
of course I am choosing the UK and I am
applauding the British people that they
have voted in that referendum and I'm
really stunned at how the Democrats all
the Democrats that are standing here
have no little so little respect for the
decision that British people made in
that referendum it's a shame it's really
a shame so you would put Germany's
interests in the hands of UK you would
think that's your closest natural ally
to an extent that wasn't the question it
was the question who out of those four
countries would you choose as your
closest ally and I answered all right
like a link the question the u.s. is so
many things if we want to bring things
forward in the 21st century in terms of
liberal multilateral international order
we need the US as a strong partner as I
said transatlantic relations is not for
good weather it's for stormy weather
let's reach out to all of those in the
u.s. of course who believe in that
that's not in the White House but in the
Congress we have lots of them and in
civil society all right thank you very
much indeed and that I'm afraid is all
we have time for my thanks to our
distinguished panel to our studio
audience and to those of you watching
around the world the argument and
analysis continue on Facebook please
share that widely for now though from
all of us on the conflict zone team here
in Berlin goodbye thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you